thank you
[Music]
what should this woman do here's the
situation Suzanne nothing she's
leave it the way it is
she's been uh dating this guy for a few
months and then she sees him in his work
uniform right
on his working reform his name tag got a
different name whoa Don Draper so she
looks him up by that name and finds a
social media account with a total
different family whoa so what should she
do why is she looking
is your mind her own [__] business
doing nothing is good yeah what's your
life Oh I thought you were dating me to
eventually marry me yeah yeah yeah
that's what and then she's like but you
were using me for [__] yeah yeah I mean
uh she sees uh wife kids she doesn't
know if she should even try to tell her
like she's gonna break up with a dude
but she doesn't know if she should tell
the wife like what's been going on man
that's a tough one yeah I mean isn't
there a girl code if you like find out
definitely no girl why'd you say it no
is there a girl code all right
here's why
Nick here's why because I have a lot of
friends that are girls that talk about
this girl code whenever they find out
that a man is cheating because like they
would date a guy and then he'd be super
toxic so they'd break up but then they
find out that oh [__] this guy's been
cheating on me with this girl that means
that he's cheating on her with whatever
right so so once they find out they're
like well I have to tell her because if
you don't tell her that they're just
gonna keep like letting these guys slide
yeah perpetuating the cycle exactly
necessarily catching them doesn't change
anything no it doesn't but but it it
saves but it saves the girl no because
it's a girl because they're trying to
save the other girl it's like hey like
you shouldn't have to deal with this guy
that's like you know doing all this [__]
and causing all this trouble for you
right because that's the first step of
accountability right but then isn't
there who knows what happens after that
the the opposite of girl code where
they're sabotage and then they didn't
really do it but then they're just
trying to ruin the relationship it also
[__] somebody's whole life up like I
don't know man obviously I want the
right thing for everyone to happen here
the best thing but like also I think
some people
are like you know Warriors in the sense
they want to stand up for something and
like they might go into something
approach it the wrong way and make [__]
worse right okay most of the time
it's like I've heard this from like two
different girls like almost around the
same time but they they basically say
like as soon as they tell the girl the
other girl that like finds out it's like
oh my God thank you for telling like
okay it's like very helpful and this is
even among strangers what about the kid
whose parents get divorced I don't know
them at all yeah they're gonna be so
cute
those kids are gonna be so cool is he
like thank you for snitching on my dad
yeah now I have two houses yeah
two Christmases no thank you so much for
snitching on my dad so here's this girl
stupid
why is she she has had something like
this happen in the past where she was
dating a guy found out he was dating
another girl she told the girl and the
girl never responded that's why she's
kind of in a standstill now because
she's like I tried once and nothing
happened well it's not the same person
you idiot she's already making so many
decisions that are stupid so much for
telling me does she want something like
that to happen but I don't why does she
also have a chocolate or cheating ass
dudes I think yeah I I think go to the
dude first and be like hey this is what
I found out this and that and then judge
his reaction oh you know do what you
think but still get his reaction and see
what he has to say first turn some more
lights on the situation he's gonna say
but I really love you and I wanna I
Wanna Be With You take that and be like
all right for sure and then go to the
girl and like like I don't know leave a
note like if you want to know about this
situation that could be happening yeah
yeah hit me up oh mystery option but by
doing that it's already kind of like oh
something is happening some people don't
want to know though even if you give him
some people yeah they like to just turn
a blind eye what's the um the clever guy
response let's say you're the you're
this dude uh-huh
and like you you just got caught yeah
what's the sly way to get out of this oh
listen angel
a I didn't have to tell you this but I'm
a secret agent oh the government oh turn
The Gaslight all the way that family
yeah yeah all the way up that's not
that's not my real family yeah
what would you do what would you do to
get out of it
me yeah
you've just been confronted I'd be like
you ever thought about uh Sister Wives
and now late this late I'll be like
listen here you like me right for me
cool you like me when I was Bradley
you find out that I'm Joe now yeah I'm
like how about you get the best of both
worlds yeah you get to adopt the whole
family you get a sister and on top of
that we could have her threesomes
whenever you want closer you're like
selling you're selling time shares you
are a Salesman bro well the best way is
just like yo that's actually my twin
brother did I wear his uniform yeah as a
reminder like how down he is for me it
makes me want to be a better person
that's that's a rom-com answer yeah yeah
yeah yeah zany plots
my twin brother is a lazy son of a [__]
he's gonna lose this job yeah unless I
go to work we're parent trapping I show
up to his job every day oh [__] yeah
yeah that's a good one so here's a boat
there's more of this there's a bonus
amount of info and I don't even know why
they left this in here but apparently
she got herpes from the guy oh okay oh
[__] so she's gonna confront the wife
like how dare you give me herpes I don't
even know why these two that's what she
just asked yeah they all have it oh she
got her piece well the wife has it like
yeah yeah how many other women is this
guy having fun with dude what's up with
guys living double lives if you're able
to do that why would why would you
assume they would stop at just that he's
probably doing a lot of things I just
don't understand why would you want
multiple families
but in this case he's just cheating so
it's not multiple family yeah this guy
probably likes the chase yeah right he
likes he likes chasing women surprise
thing do you guys think humans or men
are like naturally monogamous like by
Nature by Design I don't think we're
natural monogamous I don't think it's
naturally occurring no I think
this uh develop like what we've
structured and created it's for property
ownership like I think it's to like
you know this is
my wife my property my children
and then you have to put a title and
then you have to structure it and then
also how do you know like who pregnated
your kid because back then they didn't
have DNA tests right right so if she was
freely [__] then it's like is that
actually my kid that I'm that's gonna
inherit animals are like that too yeah
yeah like birds like when they're not
shirts they're a kid they [__]
destroy them yeah but
if we didn't have the the structure and
system that we're in yeah like imagine
if we were Hunter gathers or whatever
right like
what are the rules that they created
because some tribes were like
um any man that has sex with this girl
if she pops out a kid then they're all
fathers they're all responsible and
they're called the Lakers yeah
[Applause]
we all [__] her yeah
I thought that was the sons
it makes sense
so there's so there's so there's like um
I guess depending on like your tribal
structure or whatever they had different
rules like of uh what's considered like
you're repair or you could be pears for
the moment oh yeah you're not in charge
of the kid till like 18. you know like
it's just
is like oh the kid could walk now it
doesn't need either of us I'm sure
monogamy has huge societal advantages
for sure yeah I think I don't I don't
think sexual jealousy Wars all that
stuff yeah yeah I don't think any other
primate is monogamous
you know so it's like in our like just
our Evolution like even gorillas
chimpanzees whatever I don't think any
other for primates yeah so I don't think
any other primate is monogamous so I
think it's something we for sure created
with our like smarter human brain yeah
but it is going against biology yeah but
it is that's why I think it makes it
that's what it makes it so hard because
it's beneficial Just Born Into the
Wilderness you probably wouldn't
immediately yeah you wouldn't care about
that but that's not the human brain it
was like a smarter human brain yeah
overthinking but yeah so I don't know
like you were like oh wow these double
lives I'm like well that's probably why
yeah yeah so he's not a smart human
being that's all it is you think that's
impulsive you think that's just like
lack of impulse control for this dude
because well some people just like doing
[__] like like yeah like like that's his
advice and you can't really guess some
people like Coke and other people like
butt crack yeah exactly exactly our
biology is impulse yeah you know you
ever like you ever put like a treat next
to a dog they just have to they sit
there and literally the drawers they
can't even control it just happens yeah
it takes the human brain to like break
impulse or 100 it's just an animal yeah
right
but yeah some people just like having
lives like that like that shit's
exciting to them some people got a lot
of uh
love yeah there's very loving hearts but
I don't know like there's there's also
guys out there yeah yeah I feel like
there's also people that are just
asexual too right like like they're not
like they don't see butt cheeks and go
oh my God I need to [__] that [__] right
they're just like they're like it's a
body part this is normal people either
they're depressed or something
maybe they're but maybe they're breast
guys I don't know but then like I do
think like
so like for example some of us are more
priests disposed to like like in
gambling or liking sweets or like
whatever right I think some guys are
just their level of horniness is way
higher and some guys just have like
they're not affected like they can be a
monk because they they go yeah I like I
like bodies but not as much as you do
right I think so so some people just
can't resist they're just like oh I have
to cheat because I just need new [__]
all day you know yeah yeah for sure but
yeah it is kind of strange when you see
people with whole families like two of
them like that the maintenance on that
must be cool yeah yeah you don't have
time for anything else what are your
hobbies
why it doesn't work that much I was
watching the uh soft white underbelly
with
um exotic I think is her name so she's
like a prostitute and she was saying
like the amount of just regular guys
that you don't think that come is crazy
yeah her clients are like family people
religious people like people that look
like doctors lawyers yeah just driving
up and down like fig or whatever it's
just looking crazy yeah I was like damn
that's what I hear apparently these like
these new prostitution like you know
Services you can just like text and they
just pull up that's like the biggest
thing right now dudes are getting caught
up with it's like uber Uber Uber [__]
it literally is like uber [__]
uh what is a paper trail now yeah yeah
oh okay do you think because normal life
for them just sucks like they don't like
the the monotony of like I think it's
also a control thing right like I think
it gives you some sense of control of
your own life probably yeah like I can
just [__] what I want to [__] like it's
like a hit of anything else like you
want to feel like you're in control yeah
yeah just now because it's probably like
the I think a lot of it too is when you
grab a prostitute or something like that
like the dopamine hit that you get but
it's also the lead up of like finding
the right person right the routine of
like yep pulling up to the spot you know
like that I bet there's a lot of thrill
to that and that's why I know because
[Laughter]
but I'm comparing that with like how I
make food for myself and I'm like oh
dude like the cooking The Cutting of it
and then once I eat it you're like
yeah and I can apply that to anything
dude you know what I mean it is a tease
when you buy groceries on Sunday oh
you're not gonna make that dish until
Wednesday and the whole the whole week
that flank steak I was thinking about
this the other day too it's like you
know how like um like the Dalai Lama was
like making out like a [__] with
that boy so I was like okay yeah I was
like what because I always was like why
are all these like religious figures
expected to not [__] or do anything and
I was like oh that's like the epitome of
like not even appealing to your Primal
urges anymore everything so I'm like
that's why that's like the ultimate
spiritual figure is because whatever
normal humans desire your blood resenses
oh yeah like but you gotta you gotta
take some pressure off though yeah you
can't leave the lid on yeah you're gonna
have a valid imagine that guy has a
[__] layover flight in Miami that was
[__] yeah booty everywhere like come
on
[Laughter]
you're making this you're working also
you're probably providing for your adult
ass family yep so you have these adult
restrictions like you don't get to be a
real kid for x amount of years and then
like when you stop and try to be a real
kid you just [__] overdosing them
like how to just figure this [__] out or
chill out all the child
dating a girl who's a child star probe
issues yeah insane I'm sorry what she
wanted to be a kid all the time no she
was just like extra it was like
everything was just so heightened
everything was just so like and she also
wanted to do everything like let's go to
Coachella let's do Coachella [__]
huge let's do everything the cool things
everyone are doing every fight was
through the root every time she wanted
to [__] it was crazy like she everyone
was just hiding like if she had never
done it before Oh damn you just wanted
to chill go to [__] kick it yeah yeah
so see don't what we talked about
earlier like just letting some steam off
like yeah we're talking about yeah then
what if you had too much childhood and
then you never want to grow up see that
then you're an idiot
foreign